I've heard you say that you wouldn't be
doing anything that you're doing now if
it wasn't for surfing also I started
surfing when I was 10 years old a
lifeguard said hey I'm going to teach
you how to surf and he did completely
directed my life because when you're
looking at all the Special Operation
units to go into Rangers they're special
forces there's Marine Corps there's all
these different things that you can go
and do and one of them is primarily
focused on the water and one of them you
can get stationed either in San Diego
California or Virginia Beach Virginia it
was just such a no-brainer for me are
you saying that part of your military
career was dictated by where the good
surf was 100
surfing is a great thing to have in your
background if you're gonna go try and be
a seal something that makes you super
comfortable in the water is going to be
highly beneficial if you're not
comfortable in the water your chance of
making it through SEAL training is very
small